what is up reject nation we're gonna
watch the third episode of
one division today thank you so much for
clicking on our video if you haven't
done so already please subscribe and
click that notification bell to get
notified when our next one division
reaction is up
oh so kovian
if you uh if you enjoy a reaction please
go ahead and hit that like button and as
previously mentioned full length ratchet
and watch alongs where you sync up with
the time code for one division or oliver
at our patreon page thank you to
everyone who's already become a
patronage already this month alone this
qualifies as reaction highlights but at
our patreon we cover
plenty of tv shows with the same tier
you get the ashford reaction highlights
and watch logs
included last but not least eric over at
nerd chronic
give this guy a follow he's been a great
friend has helped out in more ways than
one was a savior to our channel in so
many ways last month uh
last year actually is what i meant to
say
yep follow him he's great let's do this
it's nice to hop back and forth between
this and agents of shield because with
agents of shield i got the classic
marvel page
turning sound asmr experience and with
this
you get the triumphant you know
orchestral treats
don't over plug the patreon you know
guys
i do agents of shield reactions on
[Music]
patreon
god i hope i really hope we get a new
credit every every season
every every episode
[Music]
so we want to watch a lot of sitcoms
yeah she just must have the biggest
habit really it was her life
yep definitely pregnant
you were at about four months now is
that right four months
every new father to be gets nervous well
i have none of steel so there goes your
theory
[Music]
strangest thing just happened outside
but whoa
have you gotten bigger wow i can't wait
to be a proud papaya
good now i know what this looks like
kicking
already wow oh it's such a strange
sensation it's kind of fluttery
they're fighting each other and there
aren't yeah they're having a battle
oh god wait don't meet you
billy well i was thinking tommy just uh
ah why choose
it's two friday afternoon in three days
maybe i should sit down
i think we have an understanding
start the clock time
your personal best yes nothing if not
prepared
yeah it's not working i can still feel
it
oh
[Music]
[Laughter]
do these earrings make me look fat
oh thank god
[Laughter]
it seems the people of westview are
always on the verge of discovering our
secret
but it's more than that isn't it oh
the fact that we're in color i think
something's wrong i've been rapidly
going through decades
so i know what you
[Music]
that was a glitch at first
so vision must have really been brought
back to life if if she's if he's like
figuring things out and stuff yeah
no it's a different person's body he's
just in it right now
i have to i think my water just broke oh
no oh goodness
does that mean that what was raining on
them was
it's the most expensive sitcom of all
time
hydrosol
well in fairness darling the baby is
approximately nine months early
[Laughter]
she's so funny
and she's selling this man i gotta
borrow a bucket
not to wear to use not to wear
i think it's just
what excuse me
would you look at that what fruit
thank you
oh no she's taking a seat damn it well
my boss mr haddocks
he was going crazy yesterday
what was that it was like a a
chattering sound like oh like
that's my new ice maker built right into
the fridge
you're fancy and wouldn't you know it
in that moment in walks the client oh
how does she not know
he didn't fire you oh sugar
he hired me good for you geraldine
is that what i think it is a crib
the baby's coming you're pregnant
[Applause]
this looks like such a fun set
[Music]
once it becomes speeding out isn't it
yes
shootout
yeah another one of their wanda
and she snapped that umbilical cord
right quick
oh no i missed it oh
[Music]
hello
that was great timing
[Music]
dude elizabeth olsen's comedy skills in
this episode are
top-notch man i don't think we'll get
away after all
so hard to escape
howdy neighbors remarkable day we're
having did you lose power too
oh sure did but ralph looks better in
the dark so i'm not complaining
there he is he's good i hope hey but i
love these matte paintings too
i know they're great right is geraldine
inside with
wanda yes why
herb is a racist definitely
i had a brother
his name was pedro
[Music]
he was killed by ultron
what did you say she's new to town brand
new
no husband well there's nothing wrong
with that
what did you say uh-oh just now
juan is not going to like you what did
you say about pietro uh-oh
she came here because we're all what are
you trying to tell me
what is that what that
christ sakes as simple as sword we know
the symbol of sword we should have said
it in the moment damn it we've been
saying
swords before we started watching the
damn show we know it's sword stop typing
better get going that macrame is not
going to hit
itself
wonder
what happened yeah where did where's
geraldine yeah
oh she left honey she had to rush home
she's becoming like a villain oh my
goodness
oh yeah she kicked her out of the world
yeah she kicked her out man
this is our world yeah there's like a
mystery into like who who
all of them are yeah that's my that's
always been the mysteries like
these people just fabricators those who
are real that are here yeah and how
aware
are they of anything that's going on
seems like they're all real
damn dude elizabeth olsen's performance
in this whole episode
yeah that was great she's great
she was the standout like her
performance was
certainly the high life for me oh yeah i
mean she she just brought so much
like she had so much chemistry and she
brought so much out of everyone
around her now the journey of the all
the comedic moments the pregnancy scene
right down to when she feels threatened
yeah
aren't you glad we read house of m so we
can get some of that
get peripheral details like she really
she cares about her kids
yeah that's right don't take that away
from her because she'll go magically
i feel like they took the intro and
outro scenes of that and we're like
let's set a show in
there which is so fun because this
doesn't feel like a superhero
show at all yeah yeah and in that moment
you're like oh damn
it's gonna go a full villain yeah yeah
yeah
is this gonna get really dark like how
far are they gonna push one though
they're gonna go that all out as i was
like in the comics
where they make her go full villain
that's that was part of the fun part of
that
moment anyway yeah like we were just
talking about before the credit stop
with elizabeth olsen's performance of
handling all this not my mind's going
and i think it's really cool that marvel
is doing this series and really building
up a strong mystery to keep you hooked
because it's starting to appear like
most if not everyone knows what this
world is
except visions left out of it and it's
like she built this world with people
in it strictly to have this life with
vision
that was robbed from her so then she has
her kids of course like
monica rambo sword interfering stepping
in there you know like kick them out
because she wants to keep this world i
wonder if they'll go and fill in
what happened at after end game and then
go in here
it's a big question because she shows up
and kicks it like it helps fight thanos
and then now we're here
yeah there has to be a little bit of a
filling gap but i like the structure of
what they're taking what's
like like especially with literally
they're in a pocket dimension and then
they change the dimensions on screen to
show you
like okay now we're in the real world at
least the mcu real world
monica rambos they're agents or whatever
like that man it's fascinating
i love when they take this moment to
become like this percolating horror
mystery
yeah yeah i feel like that's a motif
they've been building on gradually at
least across these first three episodes
and i think it's
like it's it's an attest to both the
performers
skills and deafness in being able to
pivot on a dime
just one little line can turn the scene
from light and bubbly to something that
yeah all of a sudden has this
percolating sense of dread
i think they've done a really nice job
of in the first episode it was just
little ear marks little peculiar things
and then the second one it's a little
bit more and now in this one it becomes
this whole
sequence of like each time it happens i
get more and more worried that like [ __ ]
is gonna hit the fan yeah
and it's a great way i think to build
tension to just keep you off your guard
because there's enough whimsy
that is legitimately fun and that is
just being caused by
you know the circumstances of like ah
you know her birth contractions and
things are being personified but then
there are other things where you're like
oh
you know like what is an outside
presence trying to manipulate this and i
love to
the motif that again they've been
building on of her
correcting this reality whenever it
brushes up against a scenario that she
doesn't like or that brings up too much
inner trauma or something like that
yeah they know how to do that in the
right moments you just keep it spooky
enough
like when vision starts questioning the
reality and then it just
and i was like oh crap something's wrong
with our screen
we're doing so well oh wait no
yeah it's the reality yeah it's so easy
to get
wrapped up in the world that
wanda has created that as an audience
member
you're in the perspective of like i'm a
participant in wanda's world
yeah i find that so interesting because
it's like spooky and scary you're
questioning things and that's the
audience i'm like
no i'm questioning it vision's
questioning it and then snap
they go back to the sitcom and then a
second later
i'm just on board with the sitcom yeah
like as the audience member i'm like
back into sitcom
and i'm just right there i'm not like
what was that huh questions
john you know what's going on i'm just
like i was going back into the sitcom
i'm like
a part of the world absolutely that's
good that's damn good directing and
writing right there
absolutely i'm right there with you
because it's it is that thing of i
i really think that they know inside and
out
all of the film styles they're trying to
you know
pay tribute to or parody but then yeah
the way that they're able to take those
and to really infuse them
beyond you know just the aesthetics is
is
wild because yeah it does just pull you
into whatever's happening at the time
yeah and i was yeah i was right there
with you in just being suckered right
back into the fun
yeah it sounds like these people want to
keep the world and monica was
undercover cause i thought at first i
thought she might have been in like a
vision position
where she's maybe she went into this
world intentionally but then she like
lost her memory
yeah and now she believes its identity
she's in 2d but
damn they got the questions going like
okay are these people real
yeah you know it seems like vision's
real because vision's questioning
everything so
she really brought him back to life but
could she only keep him alive in this
kind of
mind stone manipulation world like is he
in some type of
you know crazy purgatory and this is the
only way she can exist
with him this is a really well-hewn
mystery but damn you know it's pretty
crazy because like yeah they're cute in
civil war
you know when they're starting up their
romance and yeah i was heartbroken when
vision died
uh in uh infinity war but you know you
do just cut two yeah they've been a
couple for a while here we are but to
get
their chemistry and scenes here like i
was
so touched after she had the first baby
and vision showed up
yeah it's like what was the line about
likes
as your real self or something like that
oh yeah wouldn't you want to meet him as
your real self
yeah oh i was so moved by that and then
from coming off of reading house of m
and knowing how wanda
can react to kids and stuff this is
heartbreaking if
if uh if if this gets stripped away from
her if this
world that that wanda has created
obviously and not a real world that
she's creative this is stripped away
from her that's
heartbreaking i really am so into them
as a
couple i i love them as a couple
and i think one thing you can define for
as much as they're
doing it to relish or like embellishing
the world of these sitcoms right now has
been getting to know their chemistry
better
they're the marvel couple now you know
yeah they're already there they're the
marvel
they're the couple like the couple in
marvel and their chemistry
is great and the fact that you get these
amazingly different portrayals of them
and these new completely different
shades and really give them personality
they're usually pretty dry yeah not not
bad i'm not saying bad but they're dry
and kind of straightforward with their
performances they really get these all
these different shades of their
personality and performances i'm like i
like them in the movies
and now i'm like i'm in love with them
yeah
there's an actual investment in them as
individuals in them
they did it yeah they did it and this is
i think the magic that we hopefully have
to look forward to from the disney plus
side of the mcu because as much as yeah
i mean there are a lot of great mcu
films but some of them the more
characters get in there's not enough
time to do as much character endearment
or character unpacking
especially for i mean this is like you
said it they're they're like the couple
right now of marvel because this is like
the first
big scale marvel romance story also yeah
you know and i admire the way they've
been able to keep this feeling cohesive
and consistent
despite the fact that each episode is a
totally different era totally different
tv
type of sitcom i love how it's not a
superhero show
yeah it's like oh i'm so i love i love
that it's not a superhero show
and even as it's not it still doesn't
skimp on the super stuff here yeah
it's like you still get all the stuff
you would want but in a package and a
presentation that's quite different
i feel like that's the one big theme out
of house of m that maybe will come
through all of this is that sort of i
built us a world where we can be happy
just having everything we want
and that's not going to work you know
yeah not everybody is going to be able
to hang with that and i'm so worried for
that yeah
i mean like now i'm worried for them
yeah because i'm like well damn if [ __ ]
really hits the fam i mean things will
get crazy we'll start hitting the fan
i don't know to what extent i mean they
have kids now yeah
um it seems like the table is fully set
now as of this third episode
and i think in the moment with the kids
what was happening because she brought
up her brother
tommy is speed wiccan
is billy yeah wiccan has like more of
the magical abilities and speed
i wonder what his power is his speed
he's strung out
he needs an intervention that's what he
can shrink right this is power
super super strength
speed and i think in that moment she was
creating this world where she was giving
the power of
speed to him and i think that's why she
was reminiscing on her brother
and started seeing a song i felt like
she was kind of imbuing him with that
ability
in that moment to bring her brother back
in some way she's dealt with a lot of
trauma when you think about it within
the mcu the loss of her brother what
happened in the civil war
of course loss of vision she's had a lot
of devastating loss and it looks like
they're really
visiting of and on top of that you know
she was experimenting
you know like so there's a whole lot of
experience all that childhood stuff
she's got to deal with too
so dealing with all this information it
looks like yeah i
get why your mind's a little messed up
yeah yeah like a giveaway you've kind of
especially when you have the the
capabilities and the powers to do this
but also the fact that she was able to
just like
identify who monica is and then kick her
out like she's nothing like damn she's a
powerful woman
yeah she's powerful i love how scary
like in that moment like damn
yeah i actually scare you right now yeah
and to really introduce that flavor
because again she's had those moments in
the in the previous scarlet witch man
i'm serious but this was one where i was
like oh oh no
like i hope she doesn't start to mess
[ __ ] up right now yeah
you know because i feel like she could
snap and i feel like that's all right
oh no no i'm sorry i didn't mean to say
it i didn't mean to say i'm sorry vision
i didn't mean it insensitive
snap what it was an android dodge
androids are thanos snap people too i
know
yeah what were you talking about i don't
remember what i was talking about when i
said this
all i remember is the amazing joke of
the staff praise for the episode the
show is great it's a good show
it's great and i'm wondering i'm in love
with both of them
i don't want their relationship to
dissolve as it will is there anything
you don't like about it
not yet really that i can think of
it's pretty it's pretty a man like
i'm trying to i'm literally racking my
brain i'm like
what do i not like really well product
produced
the production designs are great the
cast is great the cinematography is
great the music
and especially from some of these like
mcu mainstay composers
i think the sitcom format gives you a
great opportunity to get outside of the
normal box of timbres that we work with
for these movies i
love that marvel launch with this
absolutely man
because it's a big post end game this is
the last thing you do
because it's like it's it's yeah it's so
opposite and then it's like so
light and so bubbly and so kooky but at
the same time i
really do feel a sense of huge dread
yeah
oh you know you know that like oh these
last few episodes are gonna be nuts
like you know that i am effortlessly
enjoying these right now and if i come
up with some kind of complaint
i'll let you know we'll find them i'm
sure you've
comment below yeah i really
really am loving this now we have to
wait for the next one
i guess when i'm blown by i was like i
knew it would be good
i even had a feeling to be great and i
wanted something weird and different
like my mom would always be like yeah i
kind of like how doom patrol's like very
weird and different and this is
very weird and different but in a in a
different way and i anticipated and
that's what's so good
but it's like doing everything i
expected yeah but
puts is so much more authentically
executed
sincerely executed this is good this is
good
this is really good well yeah it's got
so many facets that they have put
so much tender loving care into and they
have executed with
such precision wow like their grip on
these complex
tone shifts because this could all be
silly because of the sitcom format you
know like
some of these dips into reality could
not be as seamless as they are
in lesser hands you know yeah props to
matt shakman for
for the direction side i'll get so
pulled in that sometimes i'm not even
laughing because i'm just so
i'm so impre i'm so like wow this is
this is good
it's refreshing and there's like no
action scenes
it's like it's just this really good
character
comedy mystery i'm really uh i'm i'm
really satisfied with this
i'm very satisfied and i can't wait till
next week all right guys well
wanda vision how are you loving the show
so far
man
subscribe click that notification bell
hit the like button check us on patreon
thank you to eric and nerd chronic last
not least patron of the day shout out
now if there's anyone who's a mom at our
patreon
and has a lot of power yeah
yeah and controls a lot of people oh
yeah you've got a lot of outlets
you've got a lot of ways
rose is one of the the few people i know
that despite the world we were living in
and despite having some crazy
personality things to deal with she
kicked a lot of ass in 2020
and i believe she's vaccinated too good
for you
you're the superhero for the new year
vaccinated
sorry you got all these things to cover
you're doing so well rosa i know how
much of a strong loving protective
mother you are so i had to shout you out
in this video
because let's face it you are the lady
stark of our patreon page absolutely
but i know if we did anything to
threaten
you from having an opportunity to spend
time with your children
you would quickly become the wanda of
our patreon which wouldn't be a bad
thing she's
a cool character yeah that's true that's
true as long as you don't eject us out
the side of it you know for saying the
wrong thing we're good
yeah plot point i'm sorry for
kidnapping your children it was a
misunderstanding but they
i thought they were someone else's kids
ah yeah it's an easy mistake to make
all kids look alike
you should like i don't know color code
them or something
whoa whoa josh too far
that's not what i meant
get them shirts with different letters
on the front then
whatever makes it pc yeah
that kid has a brown shirt this kid has
a black shirt that kid has a yellow
no that's i take no responsibility for
where this part is
we're talking about shirts shirts yeah
shirts do come in lots look what you did
you ruined rose's shout out
this is why you're here's why you're a
certified critic or not
[Music]